Ok so what the candidate did well,
I think he when I asked about
the model view controller.
He got into more details that I
was really expecting that that's
perfectly okay.
But he did show that he understands
the basic principles of
the what are the responsibilities of
the model, the view and the controller.
So that's something
that he did quite well.
Something that I liked a lot, is that
he actually has he follows several
well known blogs or news letters.
He is planning to go to a conference,
and most important of all,
at least for me, is that he has his
own side project that he's working on.
He's learning things that
are from a different field in iOS
developement development something
that is very specific to games that
not everybody is interested.
But he's looking to that and
finding ways to apply to whatever
application he is writing right now.
So that shows that he has
passion he's a total nerd,
so that's certainly a plus, that's the
kind of person that we're looking for.
What he couldn't prove well
when I asked about core data.
I asked about NS managed object and he
talked about NS manage object context.
Which is slightly different, so I'm
not sure if he understood my question.
Or if it was a clever strategy
to talk about something else and
hide that maybe you don't know that so
well.
If it is the latter,
I wouldn't worry too much about this,
it's a junior position,
so I'm not expecting him to know
everything about iOS development.
Maybe his knowledge of core
data is not as sound and
solid as it should, but that's workable.
That's something that you
can work on and you can fix.
But I believe that whatever code he
brings to our code base, should work.
It shouldn't break things and
it should be a useful contribution.